hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast answering the challenges
of cell viability and reporter gene sa
screaming cost and quality presented by
dr. Vincent oprius global product leader
and European scientific application
leader at PerkinElmer dr. Janine Hinton
etter senior application scientist at
PerkinElmer and maria-paz eco research
associate from Hofer IME screening port
Hamburg I'm Alexis Krauss of laberd's
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by laberd's and sponsored
by PerkinElmer PerkinElmer is a global
leader committed to innovating for a
healthier world their innovative
detection imaging informatics and
service capabilities combined with deep
market knowledge and expertise help
customers gain earlier and more accurate
insights to improve lives and the world
around us for more information about our
sponsor please visit PerkinElmer calm
now let's get started
before I begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click on
the send button well answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window click on the arrows
at the top right hand corner of the
slide window
have trouble seeing or sharing the
presentation please click on the support
tab found at the top-right of the
presentation window or report your
problems by clicking on the answer
question box located on the far left of
your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit
for the complete biographies on our
speaker please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen dr. de creus
you may now begin your presentation
Thank You Alexis for the introduction
and thank you for joining us so today we
will speak about different options that
can help you improving the efficiency of
your research
when you start a new project whether it
is fundamental resort or drug discovery
you start with some good idea then you
need to implement the project and you
have to face multiple constraints you
have a limited amount of time because
you need to publish of to deliver
results you have a limited budget and
therefore you need to pay attention to
the costs of material and regions you
have in that lab space but still you
need to generate that efficient quality
so that is data bring you a real benefit
then you run the project and get results
positive or negative but the most
important thing is that the results need
to be significant will the conclusions
drawn from experiments for non-enzymatic
essays on culture cells still be valid
when you will move to animal models or
to the human else you would have made
all these effort for nothing so it's
really important to select the right
approach and the right tools or from the
beginning to organize for global
efficiency of your project
today we will cover two aspects of
research projects
the first one is reported in essays and
the second one is cell viability assays
both type of essays can be run using the
Firefly with a phase reaction which you
can see at the bottom of this slide this
is valid enzyme is used in nature for
communication between self writes in the
lab it can be used in two different
manners first cells can be genetically
engineered so that the amount of Firefly
whistles produced by the cells is
modulated in response to some silver
even the Firefly Louisville becomes a
reporter of search events which can be
measured easily rapidly and with a
limited cost so grant because the
activity of this enzyme requires the
presence of ATP it can also be used to
detect the quantity of ATP present in
cell lysis which can be used as an
indicator or cell number and viability
these essays are based on a luminescent
reaction and I think it's important for
you to realize what it means to use a
luminescent assay rather than methods
based on absorbance or fluorescence when
you compare absorbance fluorescence and
luminescence technologies it is clear
that the level of background signal is
much lower in luminescence Si and if you
do to the fact that tastic cell culture
medium do not naturally emit light and
the background level of light is close
to zero this also makes assay based on
luminescent very sensitive and even very
low signals can be easily distinguished
from the background and as the Firefly
reaction his a very good quantum yield
and finally a very important feature the
dynamic range of luminescent essays is
very wide compared to absorbance and
fluorescence based assays this means
that the same assay conditions can be
used to detect and quantify very low as
well as very high amounts of an
right and avoiding the need to test
multiple delusions of the sample so
let's start by reporter dream essays to
establish a reporter gene essay you
first need a seller and this is a
representation of a cell with its
nucleus and then you transact into the
cell Idina construct associating some
promoters transcription cloned in front
of the sequence coding for the safe
lively syphilis protein when the
promoter is active it will lead to the
transcription of DNA into RNA which will
be processed into messenger RNA
translated into delicious protein and
then you can detect delicious protein
based on its enzymatic activity by using
luminescence as a system reagents like
bright light press new light and steady
I press these regions bring the
substrate of the Lucid highest together
with the necessary cofactors leading to
the emission of light in direct
proportion to the quantity of firefly
whistle has present in sample this kind
of reporter gene sa system has been used
a lot to understand the structural genes
by making multiple constructs having
different deletions or mutations in the
gene it is possible to identify what
region of DNA contains the promoter of
transcription and answers and the
binding site of various transcription
factors this is very helpful to
understand how a specific gene
expression is regulated more recent Lee
such systems are used a lot to analyze
the regulation of genes by micro rnas
and short interfering RNAs
it can also be used to assess efficiency
of transaction methods and to screen for
regulators of nuclei we set off whose
binding to regulate read in sequences is
directly regulated by hormones binding
to these receptors other type of
receptors located in to the plasma
membrane can also be screened here with
a signal transduction pathway in
bring in most cases protein
phosphorylation to finally regulate the
activity of transcription factors
binding to some regulatory elements
included in the genetic construct and
finally reporter systems are also used a
lot in biology while they are used to
track the ability of viruses to infect
replicate and form new viral particles
in taking the next cells and for that
purpose viruses that have been
engineered to express the anguishes are
used
the generalís a procedure to detect
firefly Leesville expression in such
modified cells is very straightforward
just reconstitute the lazy lie substrate
with the buffer provided in the kit mix
to get a homogeneous region and in 96
well plate format at 100 micro litre of
the reagent on top of cells in 100 micro
litre culture medium mix for a few
minutes and simply read the luminescence
and the same can be done in 3d for 1536
well format 2
in this example cells have been
engineered to explore expressed beta-2
adrenergic receptor and a construct
world expression of the Firefly we see
for us is under the control of a cyclic
AMP irresponsive mount upon stimulation
by isoproterenol an agonist of this
receptor it will stimulate Java s
proteins which will in turn activate
adding ad cyclase leading to the
production of cyclic AMP e cyclic AMP II
will then relieve an inhibition that
protein kinase a allowing it to
phosphorylate the kreb protein creb will
then translocating to the nucleus bind
to the cyclicamp response element DNA
sequence and recruit other transcription
factors ultimately leading to this
transcription of the listeth ice coding
sequence and to the production of the
enzyme by stimulated cells
as you can see the more agonist issues
to stimulate the cells the more light is
generated by the system and we get a
typical sigmoid I'll dose response curve
steady light proof the reagent used here
provides a very stable signal and you
can see that there is almost no change
in signal intensity one hour after
adding the detection reagent this lets
all the room for batch processing of the
plates
agents are also available which provide
an initial higher level of signal in
fact it's always a trade-off to get a
more stable signal you need to sacrifice
some of the initial intensity but for
applications that need more sensitivity
and that can be the case of people
working with viruses and then you do not
necessarily need a very long stability
the bright-eyed persuasion may be the
best option
in addition to the fireflies Lucifer has
a lot of applications include the use of
a segunda civilized which can be used
either as a normalization control in
order to compensate for any variation in
self-heating density efficiency of
transaction or cell viability and
alternatively the second digitalize can
also be used report a second Tallulah
event for example to respond to a
different signal transaction pathway and
for that purpose we have released a twin
light Regent are going to measure the
activity or both the Firefly and the
renal a Lucifer from The Sims lays it
this Regent is based on a man's flashed
luminescence and firelight approve the
first gradient of twin light is added on
top of the cell lysate using the
Despenser's of the plate reader so that
after a very short waiting time to allow
the signal to reach a steady state level
the Firefly signal is measured for five
to ten seconds and then using a second
dispenser of the reader rain light plus
the second region from twin lights
attitude well this region is being two
things the first one is to quench a very
strongly the fireflies activity it will
decrease its activity by a factor of
more than 100,000 fold and at the same
time it brings the substrate for the
size for the rainy legacy for us
triggering the emission of light by the
second reporter enzyme
we have compared to enlight with the
corresponding assay for more competitive
premier and you can see here that both
assays can be take to 10 to the minus 20
moles of fire Silas files and 10 to the
minus 19 moles of Renny Lucy for us so
it means that we can detect 6,000
molecules of Firefly losses or 60,000
molecules of vanilla we see frost so the
twin light si is an extremely sensitive
si as you can see and it compares very
well to the competitor KITT
wonderful customers is working on the
Ebola virus and such viruses have the
ability to down regulate the immune
system of the host and finding a way to
present his own regulation would
certainly present that rapidly interest
the group systematically analyzed what
was the impact of heat of the clone gene
from the Ebola virus on the interferon
lambda 1 gene expression of the host
which is at the core of the innate
immune response typically
single-stranded or double-stranded RNA
from the virus is recognized by the
retinoic is it inducible gene
protein-rich which triggers a cascade
leading to the activation of the IR s 3
transcription factor RF 3 in turn binds
to and activate interferon lambda 1 G
alternatively a constitutively activated
mutant form of which can be used in the
SA so that the cells do not need to be
infected with the virus while all the
thyroid proteins indicated on the right
part of the slide had no impact on the
Interphone and the one gene activity the
vp 24 protein was able to inhibit the
activation by IRS 3
and his results suggested the targeting
the vp 24 protein activity may be a good
target for antiviral drug development
and such a drug would restore the host
immune system
Disko
performed a comparison between twin
light and toward or commercially
available kids for the measurement of
Firefly and really Lucy Zara's well the
Firefly leashes are issued as a reporter
of the Interphone when lambda one gene
activation and the rainy legacy files is
used for normalization on the right path
you can see the controls that have been
used mock cells then as a negative
control cells transfected with the
reporter plasmids alone and here you can
see that in the absence of the rich
activator there is no production of
Firefly Lucy for us as a positive
control cell strands vectors with the
reporter plasmid please the
constitutively activated rich protein
and then on the left you can see that
with increasing concentration of to
inhibit of proteins the recycler
inhibition of the rich activity by these
two individual proteins and twin light
has formed at least as well as the
leading competitor a kit and much better
than the computer pick it so our
customer was quite happy with the
performance of twin lights and they have
adopted this kit now one of the features
they liked a lot as well as older
customers is that at the difference of
competitive kids when they use twin
light that you can use the full kit the
twin light regions remain stable until
the end while the competitive kit after
using 50% of the kid the remaining
region was not performing in most expect
and they used to throw it away in
addition to in light is competitive and
we are providing extra volume of region
to accommodate for the devil room of the
dispensers
okay now I am moving to the second topic
analyzing cell viability and there are
different reasons why you may want to
look at cell viability most of the time
you want to eliminate toxic compounds as
you want your drug to be efficient
against the disease without killing the
patient if you are developing
anti-cancer drugs and then you may want
to select molecules able to kill cancer
cells and compounds triggering cell
proliferation also need to be identified
and eliminated as they may cause cancer
formation and there are many ways that
can be used to look at cytotoxicity of
cell proliferation from Isis use a dice
or chromium 51 which will be released
from the cells when they die or the SAS
use label nucleotide derivatives to
knowledge the replication of DNA and
there are multiple ways to use
microscopy to detect changes in cell
viability and DNA fragmentation is one
of the legends that can be used to
detect cell death however all these
methods are quite time-consuming and may
generate tumors very busy for an
efficient identification of truly toxic
compounds and other methods like dyes
metabolized by mitochondria allowed to
reach higher throughput but as I
mentioned earlier methods based on
optical density of fluorescent prisons
less sensitivity and limited dynamic
range compared to the innocence method
and for that reason measuring cell
viability and proliferation by looking
at the ATP content ourselves with a
luminescent method is a very sensitive
method very easy to apply
fully automated and easy to miniaturize
the protocol for such ATP detection sa
is similar to the one of reporter Gina
says simply reconstitute the reagent I
did on top of the cells a shake for a
few minutes and read another version of
this aside the protocol that you can see
on the Left presents a separate slide
step before the addition of the
luminescent reagent one of our customers
in the United Kingdom our crescendo
biologics is interested in validating
compound toxicity and put affirmative
effect on primary cells they have used
as a model peripheral blood mononuclear
cells PBMC and have compared several
luminescence based ATP detection kits on
market here you can see their results
for PBMCs isolated from two donors whose
poly variation has been stimulated by a
combination of MDC d3 and anti cd28
antibodies they have obtained comparable
results or the ATP light one step and
the competitive kit and similarly see 50
values with a tip light two steps kit
these two steps kits generated less
signal intensity but still it presents
two advantages over the single step kit
first the signal with the two stepkids
is more stable over time with a signal
half-life of more than four hours and
second cell lysate made in in the first
step can be frozen and pulled for later
testing in the second step of this kit
does providing flexibility in the
flowchart
we have also made our own comparison of
the ATP light kit side by side with the
cell title block it's from premier and
here you can see the results of the
testing of those kids with HDPE standard
that comes with ATP light kits you can
see that the ATP light one step curve is
superimposed on the cell title blue
curve with the difference that the
dynamic range is a bit wider for a tip
light one step which can still measure
higher ATP concentrations when the cell
title block itself already saturated
the adb ly two steps generated less
light compared to the other kids
but was able to measure even higher ATP
concentrations and the performance of
the SI is measured as the G prime value
the lowest detection limit and the limit
of quantification well in the same range
for all the kids we run a similar
comparison using drift at cell serial
dilution as a mother again
the ATP light one step curve is very
close to the cell title block it and the
ATP lye two steps as a screen research
slide however the lowest detection limit
indicates that all kids can inside it
detect less than one cell per well and
the lowest limit of quantification less
than three cells per well which in
practice means that all kids have the
same sensitivity as no one would set up
a cell viability of proliferation si
with less than a few hundred cells per
well working with less cells per well
would bring too much variability
originating from differences in number
of cells heated by well so the
conclusion is that the ATP like is
provide a valuable alternative for
cytotoxicity and poly for asian
measurement and if you are interested in
learning more about these testings we
have recently released two application
nodes which are available on the website
and to finish I would like to thank all
collaborators and my colleague from the
Pakenham application team who isn't
generated the data I have shown you and
finally we know pass over to dr. Cuza
cough and thank you for your attention
Thank You Ventura
[Music]
yes my name is Maria Cusco and in the
next part of our webinar I would like to
present you the application of the ATP
light one-step SI system on the new
partner Alma's Victor Nero multimode
plate reader for measurement of sight
electricity and cell proliferation well
in the beginning I would like to give
just a brief introduction and we will
have a look at the protocol and then I
will try to sum up the main results and
step of identification and of course in
the end a short summary well the topic
we are dealing with is actually that a
lot of drug target reviews and drug
discovery reviews report failing of
drugs and late stages of clinical trials
and safety is still an issue also a lot
of efforts were made to improve the
essays so it's pretty clear here that
when we use cell based assays we of
course have a better chance to have a
report on physiological or more
physiological situation than if we are
just using biochemical assays
and here the ATP light one-step SI
system gives us a very good model so as
well already presented it is based on
the oxidation of Jesus different to
oxygen suffering and the production of
light and in this reaction ATP is
consumed and as we know that it B is a
key energy unit of metabolically active
cells it's very well correlated to the
number of that live cell in the well so
when we have a look at the protocol and
it looks really simple and it's really
straightforward so what we just need our
ourselves from standard cell culture we
harvest them keep them in the three
eighty four ninety well 96 well plate
and let them grow overnight on the next
day we are adding our compounds so the
substances of interest and leave it for
another 24 to 48 hours of incubation
under day of the readout we first
prepare our reactions just by combining
the two fuel ice substrates with the
buffer mix it and then add it to cells
the SI plates are then centrifuge or
shake so in this protocol we just use
the integrated shaking system of the
victor level just before starting the
measurement
so the brain step steps of Si adaptation
includes of course first of all the
saturation of the ATP standard as with
the with the situation we have
opportunity to have a look at the
sensitivity and of course later to
quantify our results so we can measure
the amount of ATP year in our cells here
tested the concentration starting from
0.0 25 to 100 micro molar and you can
see a perfectly linear correlation so of
the SI sends a differently full tested
concentration range of ATP and the next
step we have determined the cell number
as you know cell lines bracelet
differently and they have a different
amount of ATP so we have to be sure that
we are also here still measuring in the
ninja and range of the SI so here the
result the results for choake one cells
which proliferate really fast and have
g2 cells which is a human liver cell
line is very slowly let's say and after
24 hours you can immediately see that
when we use yourself the signal starts
to saturate after yeah 1000 cells per
row and when we increased the incubation
time for 72 hours it's already starting
with 500 cells per row so here you have
to pay attention that when we use 2
cells we cannot exceed the cell number
over 500 cells per row where by using
--happy two cells we see her almost
perfectly linear correlation for every
cell number we have tested for up to 72
hours of incubation
other pointer that we have to keep in
mind is the influence of the solvent so
we are normally using the salt to
dissolve our compounds and of course we
know that DMSO is toxic to cells in high
concentration so here we have tested the
concentration for up to five a four
percent tmah so in the essay on cho
cells with 24 and 48 hours of incubation
and you can easily see that when we go
for up to 0.5% then the cells are happy
and healthy and we see no influence of
the signal but when we increase the
concentration we lose a lot of signals
or the cells are just dying from the
Timisoara effect
so using this data we can then start to
test compound toxicity and here you see
three examples so three non toxic
compounds incubated reached your cells
for 48 hours of incubation and you see a
different dose response curves as
expected the compounds show different
potencies and different maximum effects
so this time point as we are still in
the sa adaptation we have to compare the
data with literature values as we have
to be sure that our sa gives us the real
or the same de expected situation in the
cells and with our data we are perfectly
correlated with already reported data
also as you can see there were different
cell lines used another point we have
here to keep in mind is that of course
luminescence essays are enzymatic
coupled essays that's why it's even more
important to compare the data with
northern literature values
and yeah the last step of our education
is always to test whether we can use the
SA for testing of multiple compounds in
parallel as our main goal normally is to
use the sae for screening purpose and
here we use the circle that prime value
which is based on the calculation of the
average of the positive and negative
control and the variation of signal
within this control so the positive and
negative controls include of course the
solvent as I said in our case demas all
and the non-sighted toxic compound and
this value shall be a calculator so and
above 0.5 so as you can see here so we
have the primaries of 0.8 or even higher
or we have a perfect SA which can be
used for screening
you
and so on all to sum up you have seen
that we could easily adjust the ATP
light one step SS system on the new
Victor neva multimode Frieda and here we
actually used a lot the preinstalled
protocols which will speed it up and
make our certification very easy and
with this assay we have a really robust
assay which is which data is perfectly
in line with reported data and now it
can start to screen multiple compounds
in parallel yeah so that's all from my
side and I will hand over to dr. Hahn
danila
Thank You Maria and Vincent and Alexis
my name is Janine hitter Meador and now
I'm going to speak with you about the
value and the ease of using 3d spheroid
cell cultures and ATP light luminescence
cytotoxicity assay earlier in the drug
development drug discovery workflow as a
more predictive model of efficacy and
toxicity in vivo so this diagram here on
the Left illustrates a major issue we
are facing with traditional screening
paradigms in the drug discovery and
development process starting with
hundreds of thousands even millions of
compounds at the top of the funnel
during early drug discovery only a
handful make it to stage 3 where then a
majority of the costs are incurred as
many potential drugs fail during safety
and efficacy testing and clinical trials
so in order to avoid the higher cost of
failure in clinical development phases
we need to test drug toxicity and safety
earlier in the development process by
using more physiologically relevant
cellular model preferably those that are
is predictive as possible of native
human physiology one way to increase the
physiological relevance and
predictability earlier is to incorporate
the use of 3d cell culture techniques
during earlier screening stages there
are many reasons for incorporating 3d
cell culture models in your workflow for
one culturing cells and 3d alters
cellular morphology and proliferation
rates with increased cell to cell
context proliferation to be dramatically
different as compared to in traditional
model layers often times much lower
rates are observed in 3d cell culture in
addition 3d cell culture can capture
more phenotypic heterogeneity as Wells
mature we can observe differences often
in gene expression and differentiation
across the cells and 3d cultures
compared to those in 2d cultures also
spheroid cultures those where cells are
grown in a ball can mimic the tumor
microenvironment setting up waste
nutrient and oxygen gradients
as those that form in common tumors thus
this produces the more physiologically
relevant cellular morphology
differentiating the cells that are on
the outside of sphere between those that
are inside and can often allow for the
creation of microorganism 3d then thus
can show that 3d can reveal a more
realistic drug response for example as
cells grow in 3d can be more resistant
to chemotherapy
especially those cells grown closer to
the core of the of a spheroid as they're
protected more from drug penetration by
outside cells so there are many
different types of 3d cell cultures and
methods for producing 3d cell cultures
the simplest way or PerkinElmer solution
is to produce the free-floating spheroid
cultures using our cell carrier spheroid
ula plate or ultra low attachment plates
these are optically clear round-bottom
96-well plates coated with an ultra low
attachment coating thus the ula this
ultra low attachment coating is a
synthetic biocompatible polymer that
contains materials that resemble the
outer cell membrane creating a more
natural growing environment that
promotes toroid formation these in these
wells a single spheroid of uniform shape
and size forms allowing for consistent
biology improved data collection and
efficient imaging they're simple and
easy to use it's just a simple seed and
grow procedure as you would with a
Schrute traditional flat bottom micro
plate and it allows them for automation
simple simple automation and adaptation
for high-throughput screening paradigm
and finally we have a volume for these
micro plates up to 250 micro liters per
well which allows for the addition of
many different steps
treatment paradigms different multiple
types of cells larger spirits can grow
in these well so we've shown the that
you can grow grow multiple different
cell
and primary cell types in these steroid
micro cultures I mean in the spheroid
microplace and to show you how simple it
is to grow and use these I have a
workflow diagram on my next slide here
so ultimately how destroyed form and
grow in the ultra-low chowman types if
you're using a cell line you would start
with as your cells of interest adherent
cells of interest in the flask culture
you detach yourself resuspend them and
standard and the standard culture medium
and seed them as you would a traditional
micro plate but with the round bottom
well sedimentation then brings them all
together at the bottom and the ultra low
attachment coating prevents these cells
from adhering to the plate surface
encouraging them then to adhere to each
other forming a single spheroid
/ well within a day you have a very nice
spheroid formed it's a little looser
usually at one day and within a couple
more days after that the Spheeris will
tighten up and often grow depending on
the cell line of interest so they grow
at different rates as we can observe
here what we have is a cultured a human
cell that were seated at 10,000 cells in
a in this well and we imaged him after a
few days in culture these cells grow
formed beautiful spheroid we pre labeled
them with a cell tracker green which is
a fluorescent site of cytoplasmic dye
that's inherited through multiple cell
divisions and with this we measured the
cultures over time so what the graph on
here illustrates is four different cell
lines that were grown in the same
microplate and we imaged to self with
these with the operettas high-content
imaging system in a cross sectional
plane and measured felt a spheroid area
Ritt through with our image or automated
imaging and what we can say to see here
is that droid size is a function of the
number of cells that were seeded up to
ten thousand cells in this example and
that it's growth rates are different
depending on what cell line you're using
so it should be something you should
examine the beginning when you're
developing these models so to compare
our microplate with a standard
competitor plate we looked at to our
plate against a competitor our ultra low
attachment plate and we plated two
different cell lines in this case we
have HeLa cells on the top of the place
and mcf7 cells on the bottom the MT of
sevens also expressed a serially fruit
blue protein so we imaged both in right
field and in flirt with fluorescence
blue blue fluorescence optics on the
operetta and we're showing an entire
place of each what you can observe in
these two images is that in our plate on
the top all the wells were imaged
successfully we had uniform spearwives
and we just saw those no growth of
satellites spheroid however in a
competitor just ula plate we see that
oftentimes the spirits will become less
uniform especially as they're loving the
dents cell densities and cell numbers
are increased towards the bottom of the
towards the bottom rows in addition the
black well in these images indicates
that the instrument encountered focus
issues and this can be representative or
suggests that there's a more uneven
coding process and just like competitive
play so once you have your spheroid
growing Pro and you maintain them using
proper media and media replacement and
feeding you can maintain them for as
many as a couple of weeks or just for a
couple of days depending on your
specific model system so now once you
have them have you analyzed them one way
which I've shown you a couple examples
of already is just your imaging you can
use a high content imager like the op
PerkinElmer opera Phoenix or operetta
CLS you can embed these viability
fluorescent viability stains or you can
use immunostaining you can remove this
droids from the wealth and fix
bed section and stain them and image
them on slide these are all one one one
method where we offer a variety of
solutions in addition we offer a variety
different immunoassay technologies for
testing aspirant biomarkers either those
expressed in a cell from self requiring
federal license or you can sample from
the super name of secreted proteins from
the steroid and measure using our other
technologies are such as alpha liza
lance and Delphia but our focus for this
web webinars are luminescence assays for
measuring cellular viability and
compound toxicity for this we developed
our ATP like 3d chips for use with 3d
spheroid cultures as a reminder for
these kits luminescence output is a
measure of ATP concentration in the
culture and since it's the methodology
of how these technology works is it it's
already been explained I improve it by
our previous speakers I'm not going to
touch on that here I'm just going to say
that like our 2d versions we have two
kids we have our ATP light 3d kit which
is your original of the tooth two-step
process and we ever ate to be like one
step 3d kit characterized by a single
reagent addition stuff for these kits
and protocols we optimized them to assay
steroids that formed in our cell carrier
spheroid
ula microplates the reason for needing
specialized kits for steroid assessment
comes from the need for stronger
licensed lysis step for deeper
penetration of the reagents into the
cells in the center of the spheroid
especially in the larger more tightly
bound steroid tissues for this we needed
to increase the incubation and shaking
time and add a pipette mixing stuff if
what differentiates the 3d protocol and
the protein on the right from the
standard 2d protocol for 8 our ATP light
one step we also have this included in
our two step si these just increased
and pipette mixing steps as well but I
don't you can look to our manuals to see
that specifics of that protocol and
finally this is a readout is luminescent
in our 3d culture plates are transparent
the final step is to transfer a portion
of the reaction to an opaque plate for
measurement in a standard plate reader
to reduce them well to well crosstalk
that would be seen in a clear plate so
we recommend typically a white or gray
plate and we offer a variety of options
for those as well to illustrate the need
for these additional steps at in the 3d
protocol we took a prostate cancer cell
line and seeded it at seven different
densities in a cell carrier spheroid
microplate cultured the cells for four
days and then a save the wealth with
traditional HP light one step or with
our HEV light one step 3d kit the run
step seemed red here and 3d kit in blue
each data point shown here is an average
of just three wells
so three steroids per data point and you
can see here just by looking at the
differences and how important it is to
have the additional incubation and
mixing steps to get a complete lysis and
reproduces a complete and reproducible
lysis of this droid
but how representative then are these
this data of the number of viable cells
and culture to give a sense for this and
to demonstrate the ability to assay to
to measure cell number
we cultured do you one four five
steroids and at different densities and
live stains them with a host UV stain to
label all the cells and then image them
on the operetta at a single plane using
UV optics to the cross-sectional area
was then automatically measured using an
intensity cut off using the operative
harmony software after imaging the
spheres the stewards were then assayed
using a TV light one-step 3d the data
plotted on the Left show a linear
relationship between the numbers self
seated and they ATP light signal as well
as on the right graph you can see each
data point represents a single
lloyd measured for cross-sectional area
on the x-axis and luminescence as a
measure of ATP on the y-axis and the the
result what we can see here is that
there's a linear relationship highly
linear relationship between Versailles
and ATP luminescence readout this
basically is shows that ATP like one
step 3d is a good measure of cell number
even in the larger spheroid and that
this assay also can be used on
previously live stained cultures with UV
fluorescent dye so without significantly
affecting assay results or variability
so what about a readout for compound
toxicity that's what we want to get a
look at here we want to look at toxicity
so to test the effectiveness of the
assay to assess toxicity three different
cell types were seeded and grown for
three days we had 4,000 cells per well
and they were treated then after three
days overnight with a titration of
storoe scoring we looked utilized both
ATP like one step three D for one plate
and ATP light 3d the two-step process in
a separate plate and on the left you can
see the results from a 3d essay and on
the right but the 3d one step and on the
right the two step si both of them were
used in produced a beautiful ic50 curve
and you can see see here that the
toxicity of stores taurine varies
between different cells as a note cells
have different sizes and baseline ATP
amounts and so it's not surprising that
you get different signal intensities on
the top end so when you once we
calculated the ic50 s form each of these
these when compared them you can see in
the table below that there's consistent
results observed between eight to eight
3d and ATP like one-step 3d assays to
assess the variability of the ATP like
3d assay kiss three cell types were
seated at a thousand cells per well in
cell carrier spheroid ula plate they
were grown for three days and very
was assessed for all three cell types in
images with our two kits as well as
comparing it to a leading competitors
kit following the competition's
indicated protocol for use with clear
ula plates the Z prime value was
calculated for each kit from an each
cell type from 15 well each cell type
compared to those well at 215 well
treated overnight with a toxic level
stores boring or you can see here is
that the typical Z prime for an HCP like
3d and H type one step 3d assay I were
higher gave a better better lower
variability than the competitors assay
in addition we have to compare we looked
at a Hilo salt see Roy culture seated at
a thousand cells per well and treated
with the titration of DMSO and for one
day after and then we're running ran the
assay with our standard HTTP like 3d kit
in parallel to the competitors asking
what we see here is that the competitors
assay shows higher error bars more
variability at the high end in lower
concentrations of dsdm s so indicating
there's an uneven penetration of stores
or extraction of ATP for more details on
these assets and for more data that we
have an app note to refer to on the
bottom and in addition a lot of this
data is produced in the that I've been
showing and we'll be continuing to show
has been our written up in our user
guides and application notes found on
our website so you can request more
information at any time
so I've shown you so far is that cell
carries through idla plates provide a
simple straightforward way to produce
uniform 3d spheroid cultures that can be
easily assayed both qualitatively and
quantitatively ATP light 3d and one-step
3d kits provide one with the ability to
precisely measure proliferation and
cytotoxicity profiles in 3d spheroid
culture model a to be light 3d
to step outside have a separate life is
stuff that extra tends distracts more
ATP from tighter denser spheroid so we
recommend the use of that when you're
through it you're growing storage with
larger cell numbers and that tend to be
denser so what about a practical
application of these technologies and
it's going to show you one example where
we presented this data at the American
Academy for cancer research conference
in 2017 for this model we are looking at
a model of cellular EMT so the
initiation of metastasis
it requires invasion which is a process
that's enabled by epithelial to
mesenchymal transition or EMT EMTs
characterized by rearrangement of the
extracellular matrix and differential
regulation of ECM proteins such as eat
it here inand fibronectin as cells
become metastatic as you can see in the
illustration and become invasive they
show a decreased expression of ich
adherent and increases in fibronectin
and il-6 secretion these changes are all
reflected in a large body of literature
mostly produced in a 2d culture model so
we're very interested in it seeing
whether or not we could see in this 3d
culture models the same types of changes
in expression to see if this process is
similar in 3d we used a prostate cancer
cell line do you one four five cells
grew them in both 2d and 3d spheroid
plates and treated them as indicated
here in the the workflow to induce EMT
we grew them for 18 hours we steer them
starve them overnight or for another day
for 24 hour period and then added an
inhibitor for two hours before two day
treatment with tgf-beta to induce the
epithelial to mesenchymal transition we
had two measures then for this droid we
measured our supernatant and life fates
with our biomarker ethicist and we
measured image with a viability with
imaging
with ATP like 3d assay first I want to
show you that we did observe with our
alpha lyza biomarker kits a definite
changes in effects of an ASIC run on the
e between the 2d and 3d cultures in the
expression of fibronectin we thought for
we observed that tgf-beta and inhibitors
have similar effects between 2d and 3d
for both il-62 creation and ETA hearings
I'm not showing the data here but what
was interesting fibronectin expression
was up regulated with tgf-beta in 2d but
not in 3d cultures so with the suit of
differences in proliferation or
viability in order to determine this we
examine these same cultures with ATP
light one step 3d and what we can see
here in the 2d culture ISM on the top
culture data on the left and the 3d
culture data on the right along the top
there's no significant differences in
treatment with tgf-beta on cell number
and these are looked we looked at four
different numbers of cells initially
plated as you can see the 2d cultures
were plated higher lot less cells to
start because they self support for
proliferate more and as 2d cultures and
they well-known 3d culture we discussed
this further in the application note
referenced below but what we're seeing
with the data from the ATP light 3d and
then from further imaging data shown
below that where we culture Z where we
where the cultures were live stained
with the cell talks dye and a viability
dye called TM RM or tetramethyl
rhodamine that there was no obvious
differences in the number of healthy
cells or in the size of the spheroids
as measured with our high content
imagers what we see here then is that
minimal differences between the ATP
content content and an imaging indicates
the differences that we've seen
biomarkers are not due to so the
proliferation of viability this is just
one example of a model system that you
can use we have another that we
presented our ACR conference this past
year and
we'll be publishing student in the
upcoming f note so stay tuned for that
data finally I'll finish with this slide
which reiterates and captures the
PerkinElmer offering for luminescence
based reagents Vincent has presented you
the glow type reporter gene assays
bright lights plus neo light and study
light plus as well as twin lines for the
measurement of the Firefly and vanilla
Vista phrases Vince annamaria and myself
have all presented you some data from
our ATV light product family it's worth
mentioning here then that all of these
products are shipped at room temperature
and are stored at four degrees Celsius
they do not use D TT which is toxic and
thus in addition to performing well and
being priced competitive these products
are all environmentally friendly and
safe to use so if you're interested in
trying out these reagents in your lab
please don't hesitate to ask for a free
sample thank you for your time and
attention
we are now opening the line for any
questions you may have
thank you dr. Dupree as dr. Henson
standard header and Murray asks for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on answer question box located on the
far left to your screen and we'll answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for so let's get started
our first question is is going to be for
maria maria what could be the reason for
a very low assay signal and how to
improve it well they of course are
different reasons for the four elements
of signal so I will say the main reasons
are still the differences in the ATP
amount in the cells and also dimensioned
effect of the solvent so here I will
just say that one should just perform
the sound on budget creation and the
tolerance curve for the solvent on the
other hand we also saw that for example
black sa plates and phenol red in media
may also interfere with the signal or
just absorb it so that's why we are
always using white assay plates and
media without phenol red that really
improves the signal
dr. Dupree as this one is for you you
have mentioned that the cost is one of
the constraints at the beginning of the
presentation how does the cost of the
PerkinElmer kit compared to the
corresponding competition kit well I am
happy that the USD question what first I
would like to emphasize did the
performance of the patient market is at
least as good as the one from
competition we will I showed you some
comparison between light you saw some
compression for ATP light but we have
compared to grow kit as well so it
really you can be confident that well if
you would use the vacuum of kids you
would not lose on the performance and
despite that we are very competitive
regarding the price well may he be in a
monopolistic situation by the past but
we are there so it's me for your benefit
and as Janine mentioned to get a shift
at room temperature so there is no
additional cost for shipping on dry ice
well that counts too it's not only about
the price the product itself it's the
global price that you should consider
and well on top of that well or Okita
environmental friendly so it's only an
advantage for for you when you are using
the kitty it's well better for people
using the kids to typically in the first
time you work with DDT you go under the
chemical hood because you have to do
that but we we all know how it goes over
time people forget about one element
essential safety things that you need to
do and well that's what I did met by
myself when I was at the university
after a few experiments you just do that
on the bench and
well at the end of the day you will have
had you those of some turkey compound so
it's always better to avoid
now dr. internetter how many cells per
wall can you culture and measure with
ATP light 3d that's a great question
it's going to we've tested well over
10,000 cells per well it got Getz's and
we get sufficient lysis and recovery of
ATP typically we recommend though using
something around 5,000 or less people
don't tend to want to grow larger
steroids because the cells you can
produce a larger gradient in cells on
the inside the sphere will die die
sooner so it depends on how long you
want the cultures to is but we've
definitely cultured up to 10,000 as well
as down as low as a hundred 200 cells
per well and we still get a significant
difference and a good window in such low
cell numbers as well and we also
recommend more the two-step assay when
you're going to get larger spheroids or
culture them cells that form tighter
steroids but with the smaller cell
numbers ATP like one step is ideal
dr. Dupree as how does the sensitivity
of twin light compared to the glow
assays well 2:29 is a flesh type assays
you need to dispense the reagent so the
protocol would be different but if you
if you look at the sensitivity in terms
of what is the minimum quantity of
Firefly enzyme that you can detect twin
die T is a bit more sensitive compared
to the glow assays
well it's about threefold more sensitive
compared to bright light press which is
the the brightest of all glow kids so
there is some some advantage here to of
working with twin light compared to low
assays
let's move on to our next question Maria
this question is for you what could be
the reason if there is no change in
signal after treatment with a compound
well also here I have to mention the
cell line so that's actually when for
example we're using two high cell number
and then we end up in this situation
part of the curve I showed then we just
got to not see any change in signal as
the cell numbers just to hide to see the
variations so also here we have to
perform the sound emerge iteration
another reason could be as the
incubation time with compounds which
might be just too short and some
compounds the show the effect starting
after 48 or even 72 hours so this also
has to be validated but also the
compound concentration itself so it
always good as I mentioned to compare
the values with literature and to be
sure that when I using in compound in
this certain concentration that it
should really have an effect on my cell
line now I will say this are the main
issues you have to keep in mind
we are getting so many good questions
today so I think we have time for just a
couple more
so Maria we'll go back to you how do you
avoid plate effect while reading
well the reason for plate effect I know
that people from the lab to like to hear
but are mainly pipetting errors and so
that's why we always try to use
automated cell seeding or also automated
reagent distributions but there also
might be a reparation effect so it's
always better to have the assay plates
in the rotated incubator but also to
keep in mind the temperature effects
have a lot of influence so that's why we
are always incubate the assay plate when
we take them from the novel cell
incubator for approximately 20 minutes
before ending to reagents so that the
plate is homogeneous to adjust it to the
room temperature that really helps a lot
now dr. Hendron at our do all cells
forms excuse me do all cells form
steroids
a good question it's it's definitely not
all cell types form steroids but what we
found is that in our microplate system
with the youth ultra low attachment and
the round bottom even cells that might
not form steroids in other systems and
other methodologies often will form at
least loose steroids in ours one cell
type that tends to be not as conducive
to forming a tight sphere would be the
mcf7 cell line but in general most of
the cells that I've tested the vast
majority of them will - in forms droids
so it's important to test them out if
you're looking at different cell lines
and where if you are looking at primary
cells as well you need to you need to
test that out of it to start
start to do free as you have presented
data generated on PBMC cells do you have
customers using the ATP light kits with
other types of primary cells oh yes
certainly the thousands of publications
with these kids and many examples and
one in fact even if the kids having
developed a walk with my dancers we hear
some customers using ATP I to detect ATP
from bacteria well in that kind of
situation well you will certainly want
to check off all variations in the
protocols like letting more time to make
sure that the cells of realized before
measuring the ATP concentration so you
may need some adaptation or the usual
controls but yes yes you can measure
more basically ATP is read the central
fuel of any cell type so you can you can
work with basically any cell type which
they typically it kids
and it looks like we have time for one
more question
so dr. hinge matter are the pipette
mixing steps necessary yes it would be
nice to reduce to remove those steps
from the process but it really does make
a difference for the the tighter larger
spheroids
to have that mixing step because of the
the way that the round bottom plates are
it's hard to get all the reagent down
into the bottom of it without mixing the
plate well it's just that with the shape
of the well just a standard plate mixer
is not sufficient with larger spheroids
your plating fewer so numbers you might
be able to skimp on those steps a little
bit we don't recommend it it's better to
have that step and the transfer step as
well as important because using the
clear bottom microplates is not ideal
for luminescence readout so we can
transfer you need to transfer a portion
of the media to another another plate
for reading
then
Priya's doctor hinted excuse me super
Diaz doctor internetter and Maria for
that informative presentation before we
go I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
just a reminder any questions we did not
have time for today will be addressed by
by the speakers via the contact
information that you provided at the
time of the registration we would like
to say glabrous and our sponsor
PerkinElmer for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on the man through March of 2019
fabrics will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye